(Squeezie) - C'est l'application qui buzze en ce moment sur la Toile.
(Maxenss) - En effet, l'application FaceApp venant de l'anglais Visage Application, heu...
(Squeezie) - Heu, buzze sur la Toile.
(Maxenss) - Tu l'as déjà dit ça
(Squeezie) - Oui
(Squeezie) - Les amiiis ! Bonjour Maxenss ça va ?
(Maxenss) - Bonjour à toi !
(Squeezie) - Aujourd'hui on va jouer à un jeu, le but c'est de faire du bruit pour... C'est faux
(Maxenss) - J'y ai cru !
(Squeezie) - Bah non !
(Squeezie) - Bon les amis vous avez dû voir ces fameux collages de photos
que tous les Youtubers ont publié sur Twitter, y compris moi. Y compris toi ?
(Maxenss) - Je l'ai fait aussi.
(Squeezie) - Rha merde.
(Squeezie) - Bon à la base je devais tourner cette vidéo seul, et on s'est vus juste avant et on s'est mis à parler de cette application, et vu que je voulais faire un vidéo sur cette application,
je me suis dit "mais Maxenss viens avec moi ! On est bien dans mon bureau viens !"
(Maxenss) - Ouais, mais carrément !
(Squeezie) - Bon à l'écran vous voyez nos deux visages absolument ignobles.
Alors, déjà les gens veulent voir ce que ça donne quand on le fait nous
(Maxenss) - Oui, t'as expliqué le concept ?
(Squeezie) - Non.
(Maxenss) - Ok, ça marche.
(Squeezie) - En gros, ça vous donne votre vous féminin, votre vous vieux et votre vous bébé, voilà.
(Maxenss) - Alors toi, tu sélectionnes quoi en premier ?
(Squeezie) - Moi, je mets tout le temps la meuf en premier
(Maxenss) - La female, oui.
(Squeezie) - La female.
(Maxenss) - Ouff...
(Squeezie) - Quoi ?
(Squeezie) - Bah j'suis un peu un alien là quand même !
(Maxenss) - Ouais mais si, quand même, c'est bien !
(Squeezie) - C'est bien ? Ça te va ? Tu me pécho ?
(Maxenss) - Ouais...
(Squeezie) - Tu peux t'éloigner un peu steuplait ?
(Maxenss) - Ok, très bien
(Squeezie) - Et attention le sourire, moi qui souris, ça donne quoi ?
(Maxenss) - C'est toujours dégueulasse.
(Squeezie) - C'est... Oui, oui.
(Squeezie) - Et qu'est-ce que ça donne si je me rends jeune... Oooh.
(Maxenss) - Est-ce que c'est véridique ? Est-ce que t'étais vraiment comme ça, jeune ?
(Squeezie) - Non.
(Maxenss) - Ok.
(Squeezie) - Assez parlé... A toi !
(Squeezie) - Je suis sûre que t'es très très belle en fille.
(Squeezie) - Oh cachottier il le sait ! Il le sait qu'il est très belle en fille !
(Maxenss) - J'en suis certain.
(Maxenss) - Alors je mets quoi en premier ?
(Squeezie) - La fille, la fille.
(Maxenss) - Ouais mais est-ce que c'est pas le truc où il y a le plus de suspense ?
(Squeezie) - Ok, alors le smile.
*cris de dégoût*
(Squeezie) - Ça te change complètement !
(Squeezie) - On dirait tes dents, tes vraies dents. C'est bizarre.
(Maxenss) - Je mets quoi ensuite ?
(Squeezie) - Allez, la fille, allez, en vrai on veut juste voir la fille !
(Squeezie) - Un peu de be-bar, mais pas mal, quand même *rire*
(Squeezie) - Oh, mais t'es carrément canon !
(Squeezie) - Ok, et attention, le dernier !
(Squeezie) - T'as bronzé, en plus.
(Maxenss) - Ouais, j'ai bronzé, j'ai bien picolé aussi.
(Squeezie) - T'as forcé sur le vin rouge !
(Maxenss) - Ah ouais ouais
(Squeezie) - Ah, le vin chaud rouge, sur le marché de Noël, on connait bien.
(Squeezie) - Maintenant, on va télécharger des photos de gens qu'on veut voir en fille. Tu veux voir qui en fille ?
(Squeezie) - Moi j'aimerais bien voir Mister V.
(Maxenss) - Ah grave, vas-y.
(Squeezie) - Alors Yvick ! Ah c'est génial, c'est génial j'ai hâte. Tu penses que ça ferait une belle meuf ?
(Maxenss) - Nan, je... *rire*
(Squeezie) - Eh ça va mec !
(Maxenss) - Nan.
(Squeezie) - Nan, nan ça va pas.
(Squeezie) - Nan mais je sens qu'il peut être très beau ! Oooh !!
(Maxenss) - Ah celle-là elle est parfaite.
(Squeezie) - Ah celle-là elle est parfaite.
(Maxenss) - Si on arrive à trouver une bonne meuf à partir de cette photo c'est que c'est génial.
(Squeezie) - Bah, c'est qu'il faut acheter FaceApp du coup.
(Maxenss) - C'est qu'il faut acheter FaceApp.
(Squeezie) - Bien sûr.
(Squeezie) - Y a une tentative de fard à paupières de la part de FaceApp c'est pas mal !
(Maxenss) - J'veux pas être méchant, on dirait genre... Genre "Caroline s'est abonnée à votre Instagram"
*Squeezie rit*
(Maxenss) - Tu vois ?
(Squeezie) - Ca veut rien dire vieux ! Caroline s'est abonnée à votre Instagram !
*Maxenss rit*
(Maxenss) - Dans ma tête je me comprends
(Squeezie) - Essaie de mieux t'exprimer
(Maxenss) - On dirait une fille heu... Je sais pas si tu vois. Tu vas dessus, il y a écrit "Caroline, douze ans, passionnée d'équitation"
*Squeezie rit*
(Maxenss) - Pourquoi il fait que des meufs chauves ?
(Squeezie) - Ouais mais mec je pense que Yvick tu... Yvick t'es trop viril, l'appli n'arrive pas à faire quoi que ce soit !
(Maxenss) - Ca donne des meufs chauves !
(Squeezie) - En vrai on dirait l'actrice de Star Wars un peu !
(Maxenss) - Oui !
(Squeezie) - Du dernier Réveil de la Force, c'est vrai ou pas ?
(Maxenss) - C'est vrai, c'est vrai, l'héroïne principale, là.
(Squeezie) - Bien sûr, bien sûr.
(Maxenss) - Pas du tout, mais euh...
(Squeezie) - Nan, pas du tout.
(Squeezie) - Attends, celle-là mec il faut trouver cette photo là de Cyprien
(Maxenss) - Ah, d'accord, d'accord.
(Squeezie) - Je veux trouver cette photo là de Cyprien je sens que ça va être bien ! Voilà, voilà !
(Squeezie) - Là je sens qu'on va avoir une meuf hy-per canon.
(Squeezie) - Nan mais attends, là, mec, j'ai pas demandé un générateur de monstre, j'ai demandé une...
(Squeezie) - Ah celle-là elle est bien mec, c'est bon j'ai trouvé ! Celle-là elle est grave bien.
(Squeezie) - Si on le rend beau...
(Squeezie) - Il a juste plus de lunettes quoi ! Pour lui beau c'est pas de lunettes !
(Maxenss) - Cyprien, voilà un message que te fait passer l'appli... Mets des lentilles.
(Squeezie) - Mets des lentilles.
(Squeezie) - Qui on met ? Moi j'aimerais bien voir François Fillonne.
(Maxenss) - Ah grave.
(Maxenss) - La deuxième, là.
(Squeezie) - Ah bah celle-là, elle est bien celle-là ! T'es prêt ?
(Maxenss) - Waaah
(Squeezie) - Eeeeeh
(Squeezie) - Nan...
(Maxenss) - Franchement si.
(Maxenss) - C'est les mêmes.
(Squeezie) - Tu penses qu'il va le prendre mal si quand je sélectionne vieux, y a rien qui change ?
*rires*
(Maxenss) - Avec cette appli, tu sais à quel moment de ta vie t'es considéré comme vieux.
(Squeezie) - Et si je le rends souriant ? Parce qu'il sourit pas assez François Fillon.
(Maxenss) - Oui.
(Squeezie) - Aaaah, voilààà !
(Maxenss) - Ah, celui-là... Il est génial, ce montage.
(Maxenss) - Franchement, FaceApp, là...
(Squeezie) - Et si je le rends canon ?
(Maxenss) - Waaah, mais ça marche trop bien ! Franchement celui-là il est top !
(Squeezie) - Ouais, Monsieur Fillon, vous êtes vraiment fait pour...
(Maxenss) - Bravo Fillon. Pour FaceApp.
(Squeezie) - Bravo Fillon pour FaceApp, voilà.
(Maxenss) - Reconvertissez-vous, peut-être.
(Squeezie) - Vous aurez peut-être pas gagné les élections mais vous aurez gagné le, le, le...
(Maxenss) - Le meilleur montage de FaceApp.
(Squeezie) - Voilà.
(Squeezie) - Est-ce qu'on veut voir Mélenchon ?
(Maxenss) - Oui.
(Squeezie) - Ah oui bah je fais tous les hommes politiques ! Ah non pas...
(Maxenss) - Jean-Luc Reichmann.
(Squeezie) - Ah voilà, Mélenchon, ici présent.
*rires*
(Maxenss) - Lui pareil, tu le mets en vieux et... Pfft. Il bouge pas.
(Squeezie) - Il rajeunit même ! Quand tu le mets vieux il parait même plus jeune que actuellement.
(Squeezie) - Bah, j'pensais que cette blague te ferait plus rire, mais bon...
(Maxenss) - Non non.
(Maxenss) - Franchement c'est nickel ça marche trop bien !
(Squeezie) - Ca marche trop bien mais c'est le même, quoi. C'est lui, mais il a juste une perruque.
(Squeezie) - Ah, on va le faire sourire, putain mais mec, mais totalement, vas-y !
(Squeezie) - Allez, souris, Mélenchon. OOOHH !! Il est beau !
(Maxenss) - OOOHH !! C'est son sourire en plus ! C'est vraiment son sourire !
(Squeezie) - Arrête de mytho, arrête de mytho !
(Maxenss) - J'te jure il a ce sourire là !
(Maxenss) - Tu me crois pas ? Tape "Mélenchon sourit"
(Squeezie) - Ca c'est son sourire ? Cet homme, c'est son sourire ?
(Maxenss) - Non ! *rire*
(Squeezie) - Quand tu te lèves le matin et que cet homme est au pied de ton lit, tu fais quoi ?
(Squeezie) - Fais gaffe
(Maxenss) - Elle est géniale cette photo...
(Squeezie) - Fais attention... J'en fais mon fond d'écran, attends.
(Squeezie) - Moi j'aimerais bien voir Lassalle, heu... C'est Jean Lassalle, hein, c'est ça ?
(Maxenss) - C'est Jean Lassalle
(Maxenss) - Celle-lààà !
(Squeezie) - Mec, franchement, j'aime pas relever des anecdotes sur le physique, mais est-ce que t'as déjà vu un nez...
(Maxenss) - Il a vraiment un gros nez. (*Squeezie rit*). Et pourtant je m'y connais en gros nez !
(Squeezie) - T'as vu la... Attends
(Maxenss) - Mais moi, attends, ce mec, alors déjà faut savoir en vrai, genre il fait limite deux mètres, le mec hein.
(Squeezie) - Ah oui, mais c'est un vrai gars de la campagne
(Maxenss) - Et pour moi, c'est un perso dans le seigneur des anneaux. Naaan, tu sais les géants dans Game of Thrones !
(Squeezie) - AAAH !! Oui, oui ! Attention attention !
(Maxenss) - Il a ces délires-là pour moi, tu vois ?
(Squeezie) - Ah, mais mec, trop ! C'est le pif !
(Maxenss) - Nan mais même, il a la carrure !
(Squeezie) - J'avoue, t'sais qu'il fait cette taille, en vrai !
(Maxenss) - Mais oui, oui !
(Squeezie) - T'sais que l'Elysée et tout, ils doivent le réaménager s'il gagne
(Maxenss) - Ouais il parait
(Maxenss) - Regarde par rapport à l'immeuble, tu vois hein !
(Squeezie) - Ouais, regarde par rapport à l'immeuble !
(Maxenss) - D'ailleurs c'est même pas lui, c'est pas lui du tout.
(Squeezie) - Alors y a qui d'autre, on veut voir qui ? Macron peut-être ?
(Squeezie) - J'pourrais faire ça tout l'aprèm, hein
(Maxenss) - Pareil
(Squeezie) - Les gens je sais pas, mais nous en tout cas on peut
(Squeezie) - Macronne
(Maxenss) - Mmh, ça va hein ! Charmante.
(Squeezie) - Mignonne.
(Squeezie) - En vieux ?
(Squeezie) - Ah, donc là, tu vois, lui il est pas encore vieux. Est-ce que, s'il sourit peut-être ?
(Squeezie) - Nan mais attends, c'est incroyable, lui, tout marche !
(Maxenss) - Mais en fait, c'est les politiques, c'est leur pouvoir, tu vois ? Leur pouvoir de persuasion il passe partout.
(Squeezie) - Qui on met d'autre ? N'importe qui, qui tu veux.
(Maxenss) - Attends, d'abord je me craque la cheville. *crac* Voilà.
(Squeezie) - Tu fais ça régulièrement ?
(Maxenss) - Ouais, c'est...
(Squeezie) - Tu marcheras plus dans dix ans.
(Maxenss) - Je sais... Nan, lui, ouais, mais craquer les doigts c'est pas grave. Vous pouvez le faire d'ailleurs.
(Maxenss) - Nan, en vrai ça craint pas les doigts.
(Squeezie) - Arthrose.
(Maxenss) - Là par contre j'ai mal. Nan, c'est faux !
(Squeezie) - C'est vrai ?
(Maxenss) - C'est faux. Alors, y a un mec, en fait, c'est vraiment un malade, hein. Il a reçu un prix Nobel, je crois, grâce à ça.
Toute sa vie, il s'est craqué qu'une main et pas l'autre. Et une fois arrivé à la vieillesse, là maintenant il est vieux, et il a capté que ses deux mains étaient dans le même état.
(Squeezie) - Viens on renomme cette vidéo "Dix expériences dont on se bat les couilles". Donc t'as dit la première, on verra la deuxième ce que ce sera, ok ?
(Squeezie) - Tu sais comment faire pour voir si une pile a toujours de l’électricité dedans ?
(Maxenss) - Tu la mets sur la langue
(Squeezie) - Oui...
(Maxenss) - J'le savais !
(Squeezie) - Ouais mais moi aussi...
(Maxenss) - Tu savais que Stromae à l'envers ça fait Mozart ?
(Squeezie) - Maestro
(Maxenss) - Ma... Mae... Mae... (*ils explosent de rire*)
(Maxenss) - Cet illettré...
(Squeezie) - On n'ira pas jusqu'au top 10 ? Non, non, on arrête maintenant...
(Squeezie) - J'aimerais bien voir Will Smith.
(Squeezie) - OOOOOHH !!
(Maxenss) - C'est Rihanna !
(Squeezie) - ♪ Wowowowo, toudilatiwowowowowo ♪
(Squeezie) - Et si on met Rihanna en homme, du coup, est-ce qu'on a Will Smith ?
(Squeezie) - Alors...
(Maxenss) - Faut faire une version plus...
(Squeezie) - Male, est-ce que ça marche bien ?
(Squeezie) - Waaah !
(Maxenss) - Y a un truc ! Bah, Chris Brown.
(Squeezie) - Bah voilà, on obtient Chris Brown. Du coup peut-être que Chris Brown on obtient Rihanna ? Je veux trouver une corrélation entre deux personnes.
(Maxenss) - Vas-y.
(Maxenss) - Nan.
(Maxenss) - Alors y a un côté, heu...
(Squeezie) - Dégueulasse, y a un côté dégueulasse.
(Maxenss) - Oui !
(Maxenss) - Moi on me dit souvent "Putain mec", on me confond avec Kad Mérad.
(Squeezie) - Kad Mérad !?
(Maxenss) - Putain ouais c'est Kad Mérad, c'est ouf la ressemblance, je dis "mais non..."
(Squeezie) - Donc est-ce que si je rajeunis Kad Mérad j'obtiens Maxenss ?
(Maxenss) - Ah ouais mais vas-y, tente !
(Squeezie) - Alors, Kad Mérad jeune...
(Maxenss) - Nan mais j'plaisantais, hein ! C'était une blague !
(Squeezie) - Ah
(Maxenss) - C'était une blague, une totale blague !
(Squeezie) - Nan mais moi je trouve vraiment que tu ressembles à Kad Mérad
(Maxenss) - Oh nan...
(Squeezie) - Ah bah si !
(Maxenss) - Tu te fous de ma gueule ?
(Maxenss) - Je ressemble à ce mec, là ?
(Squeezie) - Plus jeune, et là on obtient Maxenss.
(Maxenss) - On obtient... Un bébé mort
(Squeezie) - Et si je le rends hot ?
(Squeezie) - Il a essayé de recoller des cheveux tant bien que mal, mais la calvitie elle est quand même là, c'est incroyable !
(Maxenss) - Il a mis des implants mais...
(Maxenss) - Tu veux pas qu'on teste une grimace, vraiment ? Une photo avec une grimace ?
(Squeezie) - Allez vas-y.
(Maxenss) - C'est bien on a un retour sur l'écran !
(Squeezie) - Approche-toi un peu...
(Maxenss) - Ah oui j'ai un truc à faire remarquer, regardez les gens ! T'as vu j'ai une montagne sur la tête !
(Maxenss) - Mes cheveux ils poussent...
(Squeezie) - Ouais je sais pas, pourquoi y a l'Himalaya sur ta tête, mec, c'est quoi ce délire ?
(Squeezie) - C'est pas grave, c'est pas grave... Vas-y regarde-moi !
(Maxenss) - Attends, t'es prêt ?
(Squeezie) - Ouais j'suis prêt.
(Maxenss) - J'ai même pas envie de la voir. Je n'assume même pas d'avoir fait ça à l'image, là.
(Squeezie) - L'appli a planté.
(Maxenss) - Ah ok
(Maxenss) - Ohhh (de dégoût)
(Squeezie) - Bah c'est la même grimace, mais si une meuf la faisait, quoi ! C'est parfait !
(Maxenss) - Oh putain...
(Squeezie) - On en est là. Ca c'est ma grimace spéciale !
(Squeezie) - Quand je fais un truc avec mes yeux, je sais pas ce que c'est, mais ça marche.
(Squeezie) - Et y a moyen que je sois quand même belle ! En vrai, parce que c'est symétrique.
(Maxenss) - Ouais, franchement ouais ! Nan, mais tu me fais penser à une meuf qui était en primaire, heu...
(Squeezie) - Elle était handicapée ?
(Squeezie) - Est-ce qu'on peut pas prendre une figurine... Attends, attends !
(Maxenss) - Aaah, grave ! Jackie Chan !
(Squeezie) - Il a grillé mon idée direct !
(Squeezie) - C'est raciste.
(Maxenss) - Oui
(Maxenss) - Nan mais je te disais, un jour faut que tu tentes un Face Swap avec ton Jackie Chan.
(Squeezie) - Ah oui !!
(Squeezie) - Oh c'est la plus belle... chose que j'ai vue de ma vie ! J'ai voyagé, j'en ai vu des choses, mais ça...
(Maxenss) - Achetez FaceSwap ! Achetez tout ! Achetez toutes les applis !
(Squeezie) - Achetez tout !
(Squeezie) - Bon les amis, c'est la fin de cette vidéo ! Tout est parti en couilles.
(Maxenss) - Oui. Je crois que c'est...
(Squeezie) - C'est parti en couilles. Mais mec, je crois qu'en six ans, j'ai jamais autant pleuré de rire dans une vidéo.
(Maxenss) - T'en as pleuré, t'en as pleuré
(Squeezie) - J'en ai chialé de rire, pour le Jackie Chan, mec !
(Squeezie) - N'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si ça vous a plu, merci Max d'être passé !
(Maxenss) - Oh bah de rien !
(Squeezie) - J'ai tapé des barres à l'infini, c'était hyper drôle !
(Maxenss) - Yes ! Clairement.
(Squeezie) - On se retrouve très vite dans une prochaine vidéo ! Ça nous a donné une idée pour une future vidéo, qu'on va peut-être faire.
(Squeezie) - Peut-être que dans dix minutes, quand on sera plus à froid, on va se dire "mais c'était nul notre idée !"
(Maxenss) - Oui, oui, peut-être.
(Squeezie) - On n'est pas à l'abri.
(Maxenss) - Y a moyen, y a moyen.
(Squeezie) - Je vous fais plein de bisous, à très vite dans de prochaines vidéos !
(Squeezie) N'hésitez pas à passer voir la chaine de Maxenss, le lien est dans la description, il fait des vidéos hyper cool chaque semaine !
(Maxenss) - Tu t'avances, là, tu t'avances.
(Squeezie) - Oh, arrête. Pas de ça entre nous.
(Maxenss) - Tu t'avances. Mais oui, oui.
(Squeezie) - A très vite dans de prochaines vidéos ! Ciao tout le monde !
(Maxenss) Et votez Jean Lassalle.